I am in a great mood tonight your
friends ever go out and buy something
and then you'll go out and you'll buy
something similar or identical but you
get a better price doesn't that feel
great don't you feel just righteous and
superior I love that feeling like here's
what happened to me my friend he just
started supporting one of those third
world kids right and he was paying like
like 47 cents a week I started sporting
a similar kid 36 cents a week you have
to look for the deal you have to because
people want to rip you off and sure yeah
fine I got one of the ugly ones but I
love him just as much little bargain
that's his name and I love him just as
much and you can't buy love you know so
why pay more why pay more I love a great
deal I've heard this one STD clinic they
have a great deal let's hear me out
judgey it's $100 for all the tests but
if it turns out you have any diseases
any they waive the fee gone they don't
even care isn't that great they don't
want your dirty money
it was weird the last time I was there
somebody had stolen my wallet so I
didn't have any cash on me to pay for
the test I was in the waiting room just
praying that I had like syphilis
gonorrhea something and you know what
the good Lord came through yeah that's
right he took a negative and he turned
it into a positive sometimes there's
only one set of footprints in the sand
and that's when God carries you come on
crown what am I saying what am I really
saying if you think about the joke Jesus
Saves and then he passes those savings
on to me I bought a hybrid car recently
I thought that would be more planet
friendly right it's not it's too quiet
I've already killed like nine cats with
this thing how is that helping dumb
plant if you sneak right up on them at
30 miles per hour they don't get out of
the way and then you have to listen to
their final cat thoughts which like now
how'd this happen now
it was great somebody went off third
world kid thing was fine but uh those
are American kitties
I saw this recently a new study said
that stay-at-home moms if they were paid
for all of the work they do they were
during a hundred and seventy thousand
dollars per year that's amazing
yeah and if you think about it that
means were the exact same amount of work
a stay-at-home dad would make like two
hundred grand easy Wow some of you do
not like true things
it was just fact by facts statistics
I love watching a girl clean my
apartment it is just like receiving
fellatio I just sit there with my hands
behind my head saying wow if only I
could do this myself
[Applause]
my last relationship did not work out
well because she was really strict about
chores as soon as we moved in together
she said look Ryan every week you can
clean the kitchen or the bathroom which
one do you want and I picked the kitchen
and sure enough two weeks later she
throws a fit when she finds that pile of
dirty dishes sitting in the bathtub
[Applause]
sweetie that is not my area she calls
that passive-aggressive I call that
strategic life planning and the plan was
working until somebody crapped in the
oven everybody
[Applause]
you